and here we go with the start of a
double header just minutes away there
are seven games remaining with the a's
three in the next 24 hours in mid-may
park a lot of baseball ahead of us as we
celebrate jackie robinson day today in
game one with everybody wearing 42
including today's starting pitcher for
the astros in game one yeah here he
comes lance mccullers junior he's going
to be the right-hander on the mound for
the houston astros steven at 267 five
homers and 26 rbis
swing and a miss good change up by
mccullers and he gets piscotty
back-to-back strikeouts to cap off a
1-2-3 inning and after a half an inch of
play in game one is nothing astros
coming up chris bassett on the mount for
the athletics and pitching very well the
record of two-on-one on the season sub
three earned run average one start
against the asteroids it was that friday
night game he gave up one run he had a
walk that scored a walk to maldonado who
was hitting ninth in that game about
hitting eighth but
bassett
was scheduled to start last night so
bottom of the first no score and here's
guriel
euless shoots one fair the other way
michael brantley off to the races that
ball hangs up brantley will be held at
third as getting to it is steven
piscotti
that ball did not carry him off
the facade of the stands it actually sat
there and for a chance michael brantley
thought about trying to score but gary
pettis gave him the stop sign so second
and third and that'll bring up kyle
tucker who's been a hot hitter for the
astros here's kyle tucker sending one
high and deep to right field and the
astros have an early three nothing lead
kyle tucker normally trained number 30.
today he's trained number 42 puts the
astros on the board three to nothing
this young man has become a force inside
the lineup for dusty baker two out
lightning in a big way in a big series
it's a runner aboard for ramon lariano
mariano shoots one past the diving jack
mayfield into the corner
markana heading to third brantley will
dig it out they're going to wave canna
home here comes the throw by carlos
correa he is out at home plate correa
with another bullet to home the astros
get the final out as canna thrown out at
home plate on a double by ramon lariano
carlos correa throwing an absolute laser
to home plate to get the runner mark
canna
cullers has begun to to work a little
more slowly with the runner on base
runner fakes like he's going here's a
ground ball to the shortstop should be
too corread to altuve over the first
double play there you go a double play
for mccullers and the astros get back
into the dugout
it's three to nothing strobes as we go
to the bottom of the third
michael brantley stands in 3-0
houston and he hits the ball hard past a
marcus simeon who's in the shift in
shallow right braley's going to try and
test biscotti and go for two guess the
quad's feeling good uncle mike with a
double to lead things off that was a dug
out all on the top rope for that double
george is probably leading the way out
there
lance recorded the first five outs of
this game and now five of the last seven
he has faced have reached base for the
a's as he'll deal with matt chapman with
runners on first and third and nobody
out here's the one strike pitch bounce
to third easy chance for the third
baseman mayfield throws to first to run
his home as grossman comes home on
contact and it's a 3-1 game chapman
retired 5-3 his 23rd rbi and biscotti
moves to second base bottom third for
the astros bottom of the fourth inning
beginning with red here's the 2-1
this ball's driven to right field back
on its biscotti looking up and that is
gone it's way out of here for josh
reddick a deep one to right field the
astros lead 4-1 and a no-doubter off the
bat of josh reddick for number two on
the season astros on the board early
here in the fourth inning now bradley
has walked and scored and doubled still
mayfield at first maldonado at second
one strike pitch delivered and it's hit
high in the air to right
back is piscotty to the track near the
wall and he has just enough room staying
on his feet reaching up on a 6'5 frame
to pull it down i tap it open too does
have an rbi on a ground out
there's a base hit center field so
chapman got a pitch up and away
and he comes up with a big two-out rbi
hit that scores grossman to make it 4-2
it's a huge hit ball up going away from
matt chapman and again we've talked
often about how if chapman just thinks
that way again we've talked often about
how if chappie just thinks that way 4-2
game astros leading in a new pitcher the
closer ryan presley so tony kemp banning
with two outs in the final inning down
four to two kemp on the ground yuli
guriel is there and the astros win game
one of the double header
they snap a six-game losing streak to
the oakland a's dating back to last
season and in the process with a 4-2 win
they now move to three and a half games
back